the RNC is is taking authority over the
states basically well the state can do
they can say whatever they want but the
part is private yeah both parties are
doing this like if you look at New
Hampshire the Democrat National the
Democrat the DNC was like we're not
counting your primary votes because you
are not obeying our order and the
Republicans said to Dada we don't care
that you want to hold a primary we want
a caucus here that's what we've always
done and so it it's weird it's unusual
on the other hand I think it just shows
how much people don't trust the voter
system I mean what the Democrats are
selling right now is that if follow the
old order we're basically following
racism they have said Andrew Biden has
uh endorsed this that we have to change
the order of the States they're really
drifting far apart I I I just I have a I
have a real question there's a real real
one I what would possess Nikki Haley
into
figuratively standing in public and
begging people to throw spoiled rotten
garbage at her I mean like this is one
of the most humiliating things a person
could personally ask for